the president tweeted about one of the
options on the table trade here's the
tweet from the president just a few
hours ago
he writes quote the United States is
considering in addition to other options
stopping all trade with any country
doing business with North Korea earlier
today Treasury secretary Steve monition
was on the Sunday morning talk shows
saying that he was prepared to draft a
sanctions package that would include
that kind of language listen to more of
what he said we're we're gonna strongly
consider everything at this point and
again I will draft a package for his
strong consideration that would go as
far as cutting off all trade or other
business and this behavior is
unacceptable and if countries want to do
business with the United States they
obviously will be working with our
allies and others to cut off North Korea
economically now one way to read this
tweet fred is a direct call to action to
China experts even within the White
House estimate that trade with North
Korea amounts 90% of it comes from China
so this is a way to essentially call
China out perhaps threaten them in some
veiled way you'll recall back during the
2016 election the president was
outspoken saying that he felt that China
should do more to rein in kim jeong-hoon
he later on expressed frustration that
china wasn't doing more and earlier
today before this tweet in a separate
one he said that china was embarrassed
by north korea carrying out this nuclear
test we have yet to hear a direct
response from the president other than
these tweets we will of course bring it
to you when he does respond